[music]
Hello My name is Dmitry Pesin I
work at the University of Virginia in the
city of Charlotteville at this university
I am a professor of physics specialization My
theory of condensed matter If we
talk about how I came to science, then
my path began in the city of Kharkov in
Ukraine where I was born and  I
became seriously interested in physics, apparently
in high school, in the ninth grade, apparently. So it
all started, it all started with
physics Olympiads. I remember that in the ninth
grade,
for some reason I really wanted to get to the
Olympics, and in the ninth grade I got
to the regional Olympics in Kharkov there.
I succeeded.  win on it And after
that, somehow I was already of a fairly mature
age and participated in the Olympics all the time.
In general, quite successfully and somehow
I didn’t have any questions about my future career, maybe
it was predetermined by the fact that
my parents are physicists
both my mother and my father, my
father was and my mother is a physicist, but
somehow they never persuaded me to pursue such a
career. That is, I knew that it was possible,
I spent a sufficient amount of
time at the university, so
apparently
communication with
university people left its
mark on my interests, but
your parents didn’t say that you should
follow in our footsteps and must be a
physicist after graduating from school, I
went to study at the Physics Faculty of
Kharkov National University,
where I studied for five years and, in general,
received my specialty in
theoretical condensed
matter physics, although although I was not always I
was not always  I’m sure that I want to
do this. If I remember correctly, somewhere
around the third year, I
don’t know if I got bored or something, I decided that I
needed to somehow revive my life. I wrote
a bunch of letters to
various foreign scientists where, roughly
speaking, I wrote that there is such a thing in Kharkov
I’m a guy and I’m interested in how
they do physics not only in Ukraine,
how there are opportunities abroad, and I
would like to collaborate with these people,
if so to speak, they are
interested. I’m ready to demonstrate
my abilities on some
test problems and several people
responded to this letter.  and in particular I
met two people this
way, one of them was
Gennady Zinoviev,
he actually worked in Kiev at the
Bogolyubov Institute but was a representative of Ukraine
at CERN European Center for Nuclear
Research and so I talked a lot with him
during my studies at
Kharkov National University
thanks to him, I got a two-month
internship at a summer school.
I spent a couple of months at the center after my
fifth year, but I still decided that
high-energy physics, which I would
study with him,
was not quite what I was
interested in, so I left  to
graduate school to the second person
I knew through
this letter, Kanton Andreev, at that time
he worked at the University of Colorado in
Boldir and then moved to the University of
Washington in Seattle, and so I came
to him for graduate school and defended my
Ph.D.
after that I was a postdoctoral fellow in Texas at the
University of Austin with
Alan
MacDonald, I spent three years after
that, I received the position of
professor at the University of Utah in
Salt Lake City, where I worked for six
years,
after which, having received a coach, I moved to
my current position  place of work at the University of
Virginia and Since then I have been working there as a
professor,
doing research in the field of
physics of topological means
[music]
now I am considering the
physical properties, in particular the
transport and optical properties of
systems with the so-called non-trivial
topology, of course it is difficult to explain what a
non-trivial topology is for
interview time for the public who
are not specialists But I can
try to explain what
topology is I will make a frivolous
action
I will need this belt
and everyone knows even the unprepared public
That the belt is usually worn like
this, the
buckle is fastened and the belt
turns into this
this belt looks a little worn
because I have had it
since the days of my studies at the Kharkov
National University. This is a very
good belt, and this
ring appears. If I fastened the belt
incorrectly,
that is, I will unfasten it again, twist
this end and insert it back into the
buckle.
I will get the so-called Mobius strip.
What is the difference between this Mobius strip and a
belt that is fastened correctly? Please
note that there is a
section of this tape that is
twisted,
in simple terms, if I
look at this belt in some
limited local area, I will not
be able to distinguish the Mobius strip  from a belt
fastened correctly Yes, I just have
a stripe here But if I look at this
belt globally, I see that my belt
is fastened correctly and the Mobius belt
differ from each other by the presence of
this twist and in no way
can I turn the Mobius belt into a
correctly fastened belt  without
unfastening it or without cutting it in this
way, these objects differ
topologically.
What can be said about the properties of this
belt from the point of view of this topology a
completely distant example
a distant example from what I am doing
can nevertheless
be formulated like this Imagine that
you are an ant an
ant that lives on  the correct
belt
and both surfaces of this belt are covered with
food for ants, but the ant cannot
move from surface to surface,
so this ant will be able to Eat food,
say, on this surface and will never
get to the food outside the belt unless
it, of course, knows how to climb over the side of the
belt. Well, imagine  that he cannot
convey through assemblies if I fasten
the belt like a Mobius belt, my ant
can now collect food from two
on top of both surfaces of this belt,
but if I start on this surface and you
follow my finger. Please
note that by going around the belt I end up on
another surface  accordingly, an
ant that lives on such a
belt will have twice as much food. This is
a crazy, but nevertheless an example that
shows that the topology of an object can
affect its physical properties. What I do is that
I study
how the topology of wave functions in a
crystal affects the observed properties
electrons in this crystal,
it turns out that the wave
function is a quantum mechanical
characteristic of an electron or any
particle can look like something like
this belt that I just showed.
For example, if you imagine the wave
function to some extent as a
directed arrow. This is, of course, a very
abstract description, but  nevertheless,
one can imagine, for example, the arrows
that form a hedgehog will differ
topologically from the arrows that, say,
are located all in one direction at
all at all points in space, it
turns out that the wave functions, the way
they are organized in the crystal, affects
how the
phenomena of, say, transport transport occur
electrons from one part of the
sample to another or how the sample
interacts with electromagnetic
radiation is the subject of studying optics,
roughly speaking this is the subject of
my current interests
[music]
I am engaged in fundamental science,
fundamental physics, so to be honest, we are not talking about
immediate practical applications,
but that’s
normal  This normal development of science
occurs in the following way: what
is fundamental science now
turns out to be applied science after a
sufficiently large amount of time,
usually After several generations, that is,
roughly speaking, the knowledge of the new acquired
knowledge now, although
it diverges in the applied areas of physics
in engineering disciplines, and sooner or
later finds some  then some kind of
practical application therefore what are
now
applied disciplines any type of
engineering that is associated may be with the
design of microwave
ovens or refrigerators or televisions
was advanced science half a century or 70-70
years ago, that is, advanced science
will now be the basis for something else  in another
half a century, on the one hand, it’s a
very, very long time
to wait for a return; not all
agencies involved in sponsoring
research want half a century; on the other hand, there are quite a
lot of agencies that are generally ready to
give grants for fundamental science,
but you need to understand that if you cancel
fundamental science now, then in 50
years
microwave  furnaces of the future will stop working
or will not exist
[music]
the development of physics in the twentieth century
was certainly determined by the events of
physics at the beginning of the century and we are talking, of
course, about the creation of the special theory of
relativity and the general theory of
relativity by Einstein Poincaré
Lorentz and other people who
contributed as well  the creation of quantum
mechanics by
Niels Bohr
Heisenberg, it makes no sense to list the
founding fathers of quantum mechanics, they are
all titans, these two facts
certainly warned the development of physics in the 20th century. If we talk about the
21st century about
relatively recent events, then
of course we need to talk about specific
disciplines of specific subfields
of physics, if we talk about astronomy then
detection of gravitational radiation
from black holes during the merger process
was a very important event that
will lead to a new round of development of
astronomy which will not be based on
observing the sky in electromagnetic
radiation or not observing
neutrino particles charged particles
protons. And observing
gravitational waves is like
another window  In the universe and in its history,
this concerns astronomy,
high-energy physics, of course, there was the discovery of the
Higgs vase, which confirmed
the veracity of the standard
interaction model that exists. At
the moment, if we talk about my
field of condensed
matter physics, the last 10-15 years have passed
under the sign of topology effects
in
crystals and non-crystalline
substances That is, probably at the moment
these areas plus
everything related to quantum computing,
quantum computers that are
naturally based on quantum
mechanics and its consequences will probably
predetermine the next 10 years of
research in all these areas
[music]
If we talk about those  tasks that
physicists are now facing And as I already
said, physics is diverse Physics is
diverse as in its time
natural philosophy has broken up into
physics mathematics biology chemistry so it is
quite possible physics will soon break up
into
astronomy high energy physics
particle physics and condensed
matter physics who am I doing therefore each
of  these parts of physics have their own goals and
have their own achievements from those achievements
that he listed,
for example, the detection of gravitational
waves is a success, it has already been achieved and
subsequent research will be carried out on its basis and it will
predetermine the development of this area,
but for example, the example given
related to quantum computing by
quantum computers is an example
there are unresolved problems that nevertheless
humanity, physicists, scientists are trying to
solve with all their might, even there are already
quantum computers with a small
number of so-called qubits
instead of transistors, several
computers with a small number of
qubits have already been built. But of course, the
matter has not yet reached practical applications;
this is the problem people are trying
to solve  If we talk about my
specialty in my field and talk
about what practical consequences the
activities that
we are conducting may have, probably the most important of them
will be the issue of obtaining energy and
storing energy in some kind of batteries,
this is now a primary
task, naturally, in view of  in view of the crisis in
hydrocarbons and
energy sources that are based on
hydrocarbon production. If we talk about
scientific problems in
high-energy physics, we can mention
the deviation from the standard model, in
particular, the famous large
hadron collider on which the
Higgs boson was actually found was
not built in order to find the Higgs boson  in
order to find a deviation from the
standard model of interaction
that we now have from how we
understand how nature works. So far,
no deviations from this standard
model have been found, which certainly
makes many scientists depressed. If we
talk about cosmology, astrophysics and
connections with high energy physics  with
particle physics, the main mystery
at the moment is essentially the
existence of dark matter, an explanation
of what it is, where it comes from, and
whether there is a connection between this dark matter and the
Stan model of interactions as we
know it. But in these some
directions, apparently, it will move
science in the near future
[music]
If we talk about the most promising
areas of physics, then in addition to
those that I have already listed, we
can probably mention biophysics and the
use of ideas and methods that
were developed for other tasks completely
in biology. Probably this is one of the most
interesting areas simply because  that
it is connected with the fact that the wave worries
any person with life, with its
origin, with human biology,
with aging, and ultimately with the extension of
life, that is, what we all think about
when we are not doing physics. In general,
biophysics can be considered. Therefore,
bringing physics into
biology, neurobiology, is probably
very, very interesting direction
[music]
I would like to demonstrate one of the
methods for solving physical problems
that can be applied to virtually
any branch of physics
equally successfully in order not to
choose any specific section and
method for solving physical problems that
I would like to describe is called the
analysis method  dimensions, in order to
understand what the method consists of, it is necessary to
mention what the dimension of a
physical quantity is, in fact, the dimension of a
physical quantity shows its relationship
with basic quantities,
some systems of units, for example in the
International system of units, the so-
called basic units that
describe all mechanical phenomena
are mass, length and  time,
using units of mass, length and time, you
can construct any quantity that is
associated with the mechanical movement of an object,
for example, the speed of an object
has the dimension of length divided by
time,
I will denote length with the Latin
symbol L time with the Latin symbol T,
for example, the dimension of force as we know
According to Newton’s second law, force is
equal  mass by acceleration, respectively, the
dimension of force is the product of the
dimension of mass and acceleration, the
dimension of mass is simply mass, the
dimension of acceleration can be understood by
noting that acceleration is the rate of
change of speed, so acceleration
has the dimension of length
divided by the square of time, and so
on, so we can construct any value. For
example, if we want  apply this
method of dimensional analysis in its most
primitive form we can give you The
following question let's say we have a ball
made of some material
with a radius R and having a density
Here e the Greek letter rho describes
the density of this material How can we
Using the method of dimensional analysis
find  we can reason about the mass of this ball
in the following way, using the
existing values ​​of density and the size of
the ball, we must construct such a
combination of these quantities that had the
dimension of mass in order to
understand how to construct this quantity.
Let's look at the dimensions of quantities
and densities. Naturally, it has
the dimension of mass divided by the cube  length
per volume density is the mass of a unit
volume of a substance, the
radius of a ball naturally has the
dimension of length. That is, it is measured
in meters.
To get a value with the dimension of
mass, obviously we must take the density of the
ball and multiply its size by the cube. This is a
completely trivial statement
that suggests that in order to find  the
mass of the ball, we must multiply its
density by its volume, but nevertheless, from the
point of view of the dimensional analysis method,
we can argue like this, the complete
expression with all the coefficients
restored looks like this: the mass is
equal to 4 Pi by 3 R cubed multiplied by the
density by ru And despite all  the
simplicity and triviality of this
result is very important, for example, it
says that if a person
has two potato tubers, one of
which is two times larger than the other, then the
larger of them contains 8 times more
food, this is an important fact for any person,
naturally, dimensional analysis methods
do not allow  we need to restore the numerical
coefficient in the formula for the mass that
we received 4 Pin 3, unfortunately it
cannot be obtained, it can only be obtained by
direct calculations, this method of
dimensionality analysis of dimensionality is
very important in physics and it allows you to
obtain results to obtain answers
where a more accurate, more detailed solution is
completely unobvious  in my own
life there was an episode that led me to
understand the importance of this method and is associated
with my mother. When I was very little,
I did not know and, or rather, did not remember the correct
formula for the volume of a ball, which I
wrote here: 4 Pi by 3 R cubed. Or rather,
I understood  that there is a formula that
contains 4 Pin 3 R cubed And there is a formula
that contains 4pr squared this is
the formula for the surface of the
surface area of ​​a sphere when I was very
little I did not know the difference between these
designed I came to my mother and asked my mother
Which one described the Volume  ball and mom
said, well, think about it, you are talking about volume
and you are trying to attribute to this volume a
value with the dimension of the square of the length,
that is, the first four squares have
dimensions of the square of the length, the volume of the ball
can be the square of the length, then I was
stunned by the simplicity and power of this
reasoning because I suffered for a long time  I
couldn’t understand which of these formulas is
correct, and since then I don’t remember
how old I was, probably 12, I’m
probably ashamed to admit that at the
age of 12 I didn’t know the formula for the volume of a sphere, but
nevertheless, since then I’ve been checking
the dimensions of all the quantities that I
ever I calculate because it is an
incredibly powerful way
[music]
one language of
inhuman communication probably does not have
such a strong influence on how a
person engages in science, of course
knowledge of the Russian language helps simply in
personal communication. In a sense, it
determines belonging to someone  for a circle of
people this is important for a person, a person
is a
social animal, if I may say so,
knowledge of the Russian language or any
other language allows you to have access to a
source of information in this language. The
Russian language in this sense is a special
language because it is the language of physics.
Soviet physics there are many journals
of which  articles are written in Russian
and which cannot be found anywhere else these
articles are often important so
the ability to read them Some of them
have not been translated into English
is generally a pleasant consequence
of knowing the language But of course language is more
important socially than
scientifically
[music  ]
If we talk about the word of the year, or even more so the
word of the decade, then we need to distinguish
again between different areas of physics. I guess
I need to talk about the area of ​​physics
in which I work and for this area of
physics I work in
condensed matter physics,
many particle physics, the
main word lately is
the phrase
quantum entanglement this
phrase describes a situation in
which the so-called wave functions of
various objects are not all
parabel, they are inseparable from
each other, in fact this is another way of
talking about quantum correlations what we
are talking about The fact is that
our world is very complex, it consists of
many particles  set of objects and, in
principle, one could assume that
all these objects, all these particles
are described by one large
gross function of the Universe, but in
practice, of course, such a description is
meaningless because it would simply be
impossible to determine such a
complex function and the question arises about the
gross function of some  then individual
objects of individual particles it turns out
that if
two objects interact, then they
are described by such a single wave
function and the wave function of each of
these objects, roughly speaking, does not exist,
that is, it is impossible to fully provide a
quantum description of such an object without
knowing the state of its
partner with which they interact,
then  there is a wave function of these
interacting objects is not
separable, it does not break down into a
gross function of individual individual
parts, but you can say, for example, you can
say that thanks to quantum
entanglement, there is a new way to
classify the phases of substances, for example,
everyone knows from their school days that
there is a
gaseous phase, a liquid phase and a solid
phase  crystalline phase of substances sometimes
plasma is added to this list
it turns out that the
concept of quantum entanglement leads to
another classification of
phases in particular electronic phases of
matter in some phases the wave
functions are entangled and in others
they are not. That is, this is another
one more  a way
to classify the state of matter
accordingly, this quantum entanglement along the path.
This purely
quantum mechanical characteristic of
particles, on the one hand, is the basis
for another classification of the phase of
matter, on the other hand, the
action of quantum computers is based on it,
on the third hand,
this concept lies at the foundations of quantum
mechanics and  thinking about it
leads to the understanding of quantum
mechanics that we now have, so
probably for people in my
field this is the most important word or
two of recent times
[music] it’s
impossible to answer the question about my preferences in books or movies
because the question  should be asked
differently reading or a movie
book is probably no longer a
source of printed information
I read more or less all the time
but reading books takes up Honestly, I have
very little of this total time That
is, I read for work, I read
articles that are related to  The general human themes that interest
me
are related to the society in which we live,
so reading occurs continuously;
reading books is no longer the
only type of this very reading
that is available to a person. I
also love cinema very much, but I do not use it
to learn the Secret Arts
and cinematography for that  to
rest and relax That's why I
really love films with light
[music]
my memory is designed in such a way that I
remember the general outline of the story and
my feelings about it But not But not the
details themselves, some plots, so for
example I remember that I swallowed Quiet Don
I couldn’t tear myself away I completely
just
devoured it from the master Margarita Quiet Don
Sholokhov The Master and Margarita Bulgakova I
can’t tear myself away These are probably
iconic works, these are my
favorite books
[music]
I’ve said the name Migdal already
and I’ll probably say it again  since Migdal
was involved in many things, he is particularly
famous for his work on nuclear physics I am
in physics and work on physics
in many particle systems many partial
systems
[music]
What are three pieces of advice I would give to young scientists
the most important and first piece of advice is
to start early essentially like me  I have already said that
physics requires knowledge of a very large
number of facts and this knowledge
accumulates over a very long
time. The
second advice that I would give concerns
the choice of a research topic, especially if we are
talking about research in
graduate school about research on such
traces that will be later. The topic of a scientific
dissertation needs to be chosen complex
complex questions, questions in which nothing
is clear and in which the
most interesting things probably happen as a result,
precisely because no one
understands anything. That is, probably in youth it is
better to solve complex problems, then with
age you can solve simple problems and
give complex tasks to young people  for people,
here is the
last last piece of advice, probably
practical advice. If suddenly a young
man begins to engage in some kind of
scientific task, you need to know the history of
the issue,
knowing the history of the issue creates a feeling of the
importance of what this young man
is doing without a feeling of importance from what
you are doing, it is very difficult to
do something  long years, namely, long
years of research that takes
serious research that then
leads to a scientific degree. Therefore, you need to
read, you need to know the literature, you need to
know who has already thought about it,
thought about it, and then there will be a feeling of the
importance of what is happening, then it will be easier
to agonize over the task
[music]
is worth it if
There are data for this and
there is a feeling that no other
profession is suitable
[music]